[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
los observadores de france 24 cerros
blanco como siempre un gusto saludarlos
esta semana comenzamos en eeuu donde les
explicamos el porqué de los recientes
ataques violentos a asiáticos
estadounidenses que se han disparado
este último mes también iremos a la
república democrática del congo donde
nuestro observador denunció el trabajo
infantil que se presenta en las minas de
oro de kivú del sur
[Música]
el último menciones virales en las redes
sociales vídeos como este en el que
muestran a estadounidenses de origen
asiático menudo hacia no siendo
agredidos físicamente e insultados
estas imágenes muestran una realidad el
aumento de las agresiones contra los
asiáticos en eeuu desde que comenzó la
pandemia en 2019
sobre
[Música]
para muchos esta intolerancia en la
causa del cuoteo los salones de masaje
de atlanta el 16 de marzo en el que un
hombre blanco mató a tiros a ocho
personas seis de ellas de ascendencia
asiática
russel jones es el cofundador de una
iniciativa que registra los actos de
violencia contra los asiáticoamericanos
comenzamos a recolectar datos en marzo
de 2020 sobre testimonios directos de
racismo anti asiático y hasta la fecha
hemos contabilizado más de 3000
a menudo los empujan a veces nos lanzan
piedras y botellas y muy a menudo nos 12
o nos escupen no esperábamos que el
presidente trump incitar a más odio en
torno al virus incluso términos como
virus chino una y otra vez incluso
cuando se le dijo que no debía hacerlo
zaira
con charles baker hizo el virus
biológico algo racial y esto creó esta
asociación automática del virus con las
personas en la historia de eeuu y un
temor al peligro amarillo o sea que los
asiáticos vengan en pedir que estados
unidos con sus hordas de inmigrantes y
se robó en puestos de trabajo pero
también que traigan enfermedades a pesar
del oscurantismo en la tristeza de estas
ideas agentes están organizando para
apoyar a la comunidad no sólo a los
asiáticos estadounidenses sino también a
nuestros aliados veo que la comunidad
asiático estadounidense se está
reuniendo en este momento gente de todas
las clases sociales universitarios a
estudiantes desde ingenieros a
profesores desde sindicalistas a
representantes de la iglesia todo el
mundo se está movilizando para resistir
el racismo hoy en día los
estadounidenses de ascendencia asiática
están pensando realmente en su lugar en
la sociedad estadounidense esto nos hace
decir no queremos crear un nuevo eeuu al
que se pertenezca jobvite desde nos esos
actos de violencia son juicios con
ciudadanos de ascendencia asiática y
pidió que cesara el 18 de marzo se
celebró en el congreso una audiencia
sobre el tema la primera en 30 años
[Música]
y estos niños buscan oro las imágenes
fueron grabadas a mediados de marzo por
nuestro observador y galón de agua en
equipos del sur al este de la república
democrática del congo
estos niños trabajan de 8 a 9 horas al
día y trabajan de lunes a domingo para
ser nuestra en arena o piedras de los
pozos de oro o de mons y subsidios a los
transportan desde la colina de mieles y
hasta las lavanderías de callaway de la
colina
scolari de kaui para que los abogados
niños que vivimos en esta mina tienen
entre 10 y 12 13 14 años y el mayor
tiene 17 años él empieza a la receta
festivo del sur tiene grandes
yacimientos de oro pero más del 80 por
ciento de la población local vive por
debajo del umbral de la pobreza para
mantenerse a sí mismos ya sus familiares
los niños se ven obligados a trabajar en
las minas en condiciones difíciles a
pesar de que el código minero del país
lo prohíbe
durante el día en el río caya pues
siempre hay niños que lavan los
minerales todos los días es como si el
estado no existiera la policía minera
pasa todos los días pero no les dice
nada a estos niños que son de riesgo que
son los riesgos a los que están
expuestos estos niños son muchos por
ejemplo hay derrumbes hay casos de
asfixia en los pozos de oro y delicada
de asfixia de ruido
y estos niños corren incluso el riesgo
de ser golpeados por los adultos en las
minas porque los acusan de ser ladrones
el estado congoleño tiene que poner fin
a este sistema que se ha convertido en
algo habitual en la república
democrática del congo deben utilizar su
poder para que estos niños vuelvan a la
escuela
menezes a pnv a alcohol en 2017 bajo la
presión de varias ong entre ellas
amnistía internacional el gobierno
congoleño dijo querer erradicar el
trabajo infantil en las actividades
mineras para el 2025 pero según nuestro
observador nada ha cambiado
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro programa por esta semana
recuerde que todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla para que usted
envíe sus fotos y vídeos aficionados
hasta pronto
[Música]